Florida is at the center of a republican
Civil War that I absolutely love
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
is almost certainly going to win
re-election it's just what the polls say
and everybody should get out there and
vote for Charlie Crist but in all
likelihood the winner is going to be Ron
DeSantis Donald Trump has announced a
series of rallies including in Florida
in support of 2022 candidates he is
doing a rally in Florida with Marco
Rubio who's running for re-election to
the Senate but Ron DeSantis is
conspicuously excluded from that we know
what this is all about my friends this
is a snub because Trump is furious with
DeSantis DeSantis when asked has not
ruled out running in 2024 for the
Republican Presidential nomination even
if even if Donald Trump wants the
nomination as well Donald Trump expects
unending loyalty from other Republicans
what Trump wants DeSantis to have said
is
I won't challenge Donald Trump this
nomination is trumps if he wants it if
he doesn't then I'll think about my
political future DeSantis hasn't done
that and why hasn't DeSantis done it
well if you look at the betting markets
you see that DeSantis is essentially
running tied with Donald Trump when you
ask people who do you believe will be
the Republican nominee these aren't
polls and the polls Trump is still doing
much better these are betting markets
DeSantis and Trump have been right neck
and neck for a couple of months at this
point in time DeSantis knows he is
positioned to maybe be the Republican
Presidential nominee which would be a
big Boon for him without a doubt and
this is making Trump Furious uh
political reports Trump to hold rally in
Florida with Rubio but not DeSantis
the apparent snub are angered some
people within DeSantis orbit who
complained that the Florida Governor's
team was not informed of the rally prior
it is abundantly clear what is going on
here Donald Trump correctly and
accurately sees Ron DeSantis as a threat
to Trump's potential desire to be the
Republican nominee in 2024 and so this
Civil War is growing and growing and
growing I've told you before the
numerous reports of Donald Trump
privately fuming at Ron DeSantis and
increasingly we have seen Ron DeSantis
publicly distance himself from Donald
Trump when it comes to Florida's covet
response and other things this is a
great thing this is a great thing the
more Strife there is from now because
listen 2024 starts in 12 days after the
November midterm the more Strife there
is between these folks leading up to the
primary I believe the more they will
weaken each other and hopefully hurt
themselves in the event eventual general
election of 2024 we will have plenty of
time to discuss that but you really love
to see it
the chances that your login credentials
have been leaked in a data breach are
higher than you might think but you can
actually check if you go to aura.com
Pacman you can try Aura for free our
sponsor Aura scans the dark web for your
personal information login credentials
social security number and sends you
alerts sign up and you could be shocked
to see how many alerts you get on Aura
one of our team members found his login
credentials in three different data
breaches now of course he changed his
passwords right away I've told you
before about one of my accounts getting
hacked scary feeling but Aura also does
so much more by automatically requesting
the removal of information from data
search engines giving you fast alerts on
suspicious credit inquiries Aura has
password management malware protection
for all of your devices and Aura also
helps you manage what your kids can do
on their devices by restricting certain
apps it's really like a Swiss army knife
of online security and you can try Aura
for free for two weeks at aura.com
Pacman the link is down below